Well,
thanks for coming in your lunch off for what I'm going to say isn't going to
give you indigestion.
Okay.
Um,
let's see.
well I've written about the suffragettes in the past.
Um,
and I'd always concentrated on what they did in terms of their militancy.
Remember,
these are the women who fought for the vote in a very insistent,
outrageous,
provocative,
direct action kind of way.
Um,
so I talked about that campaign,
which really started with shouting at meetings,
interrupting politicians,
what right through to burning down churches and attacking works of art over a
period of about eight years.
So it's,
it was very controversial and deeply unpopular.
So I'd written about that.
It also written about how modern they were,
how they invented political merchandising and marketing and branding.
The brand to that campaign really beautifully more about that in a moment.
Had a color scheme of purple,
white and green.
And they branded and merchandise their slogan votes women in all sorts of
different ways.
So I found that very kind of sexy and exciting.
And then I got to thinking about,
well,
who were these amazing women?
I mean,
what kind of person would do that would make that journey would become a
suffragette because make no mistake,
it was the most unpopular campaign,
political campaign of the 20th century.
Um,
it was a coming out moment for anybody who said,
uh,
by team in terms of conversation or by wearing a badge that they were
suffragettes because there was so detested and so losed I mean all they wanted
was the vote,
but the,
the,
the frontier of them you're asking me for it nicely but demanding it
outrageously and noisily and cheekily and violently was something that people
just couldn't stomach.
Um,
so I was interested in,
in,
uh,
who,
who they were,
where they came from,
what their biographies or what their backstories are,
what that pre history is.
And I was interested in their mums and dads and their siblings,
their brothers and sisters,
the neighbors and family groups because you have to have your family on your
side if this was going to work and your family have to be quite extraordinary to
buck year because they're going to get a lot of flack from neighbors and
colleagues and family members.
If you support your daughter embarking on this kind of campaign.
So I was really interested to get kind of the backstories on them.
Of course,
I'm the lucky suffragettes if you like,
who possessed and they have a long suffragette career are extremely fortunate.
They've got supportive hospitals and files,
etc. Which are some women who found,
found out that their fathers and families,
we're not going to support it.
You know,
they,
they had some very tough choices that either sort of shut up and stop it or they
leave home.
They thrown out,
they call start there,
disinherited that is uh,
in many of them had that experience.
So marriages rocked and ended and some engagements broken off.
Quite a lot of women involved in the campaign were lost their jobs and in one of
their papers called [inaudible],
there's a regular feature where suffragettes or writing in asking in situ in the
situations wanted column and the classified ads section explain they need a job
because they've been dismissed from their post.
And you could be dismissed for even having a suffragette leaflet on your desk.
Not,
they've been spotted smashing a window or anything like that.
It was just the fact that you were interested,
you'd been to a meeting was enough to get you dismissed with mostly pretty
disastrous results.
So I was fascinated in the strength of character and the strength of a family
unit that can do this kind of behavior.
I was also interested in diversity.
I was interested in all kinds of women who are getting involved in this.
So I did kind of a lot of digging away at that kind of story.
I found some great examples of diversity.
I was interested in it being a regional,
at looking at the regions rather and understanding how nationwide it was,
which it was.
They had branches all over the country quite quickly.
Um,
in Scotland and Ireland in Wales and all of the United Kingdom,
all over England.
So that was a measure of its success and organization.
And they even had shops selling their merchandise,
suffragette shops,
selling paper,
white and green stuff all over the country.
So that I thought was pretty,
pretty sexy too.
And I was interested in working class movement because they've been very much
marginalized in this story.
There.
It was often said that the middle of the suffragettes were just middleclass
hobbyist.
They weren't interested in working class room and nothing could be further from
the truth.
So lots of things to go and look for.
And to weave into this story.
Well I have to talk about the ladies on the screen.
First of all by saying these are undoubtedly the stars of the campaign.
Um,
on the far on the far left is Sylvia Pancoast who's an artist and designer.
She gives the WSP the military campaign,
the look,
she designs exhibitions,
designs,
logos.
She is responsible for the branded look of the Wsp you,
uh,
sisters in next to her.
The next image along she is,
uh,
she has a first class degree in law,
but because she's a woman,
you couldn't be a lawyer then,
which was irksome to say the least.
So she gave her a great strategic thinking and logic and planning skills into
the campaign.
And she was their big thinker really.
And Mrs Pancoast,
the mother who got them all together.
And founded the women's social political union in her parlor in 1903 great
charismatic woman.
She could fire up a room and she could light up a room very quickly.
Um,
all of them could actually,
all the Pancoast girls were charismatics.
Um,
she's a tiny creature.
Her shoe size was too,
but she's like a cannonball when she was,
when she got going,
you know,
he's amazing.
Um,
and then Andy Kenney who is a mill girl from Oldham who joined the campaign,
um,
very early on,
she a very senior member of the campaign.
Uh,
she's supposed to go for the campaign and she can reach into working class
communities and recruit women in the way that the Pankhurst curse couldn't
always.
So she's a big part of the story.
And,
um,
she was,
you know,
very pretty and the subject of management postcards,
which women collected at the time,
this is the candidate that's the context and suffered.
It's are operating.
And um,
Mommy's a suffragette is your wife was suffrage act,
you know,
domestic chaos comes when women are involved in politics and bought the vote.
How dare they.
Um,
and I just this,
there's hundreds of these flying around,
different designs,
thousands of them being sent around the country at this time.
It's the golden age of the postcard.
People kind of made arrangements to see each other with these postcards.
London had 12 postal deliveries a day,
those were the days.
And there they're a bit like tweets and texts.
You could make an arrangement in the morning and you could confidently expect
your postcard to be delivered and meet your friends in the afternoon for tea or
whatever.
And so in the evening.
So it was a brilliant means of communication.
So,
you know,
civilization is going to collapse if women get the vote.
And certainly domestic chaos reigns whenever they want to,
when they're at whatever they're asking for it.
It's the first suffragette postcard I for bought and offered.
It was just so daft.
I liked it.
Um,
suffragettes who've never been kissed.
And this is to frighten young girls from being involved in the campaign because
they said,
you know,
this is what happens when you don't take your life seriously.
Um,
and if you're involved in politics,
you're going to be so unattractive to men.
You're never going to be cast.
You can have a very site unfulfilled life.
So the messages,
you know,
it's the sexual frustration of an unfulfilled life is driving these women into
asking for the vote.
There we have it,
an apocalyptic vision.
When women vote,
this is what's going to happen.
There's about 10 in this series,
which are fantastic.
Layer isn't dark of course.
Um,
I love the idea of what happens when women vote.
They have their friends around,
how dare they,
they have cigarettes,
they smoke,
they have chocolate,
they just hang out and just relax while their husbands were in the kitchen,
getting a ray red in the face and coping very badly with a balling child and the
washing and the everything.
So the role reversal of roles here is,
it's a horrible prospect,
is horrible.
It's a topsy turvy world and it's,
it's to be stopped early in its tracks.
Uh,
we've got to make sure this doesn't happen.
And when women vote,
they're going to ask men to marry them,
not to going to cast,
sit around and wait,
hoping it's going to happen.
So they're going to kind of take the initiative and that's going to be horrible
too.
This is Annie Kenny.
I'm dressed up to lead a procession.
Um,
as I said,
she could reach into working class communities everywhere all over the country.
And these are the clothes she wore when she worked in the cotton mills and
older.
Um,
she was a half time or from the age of eight when she was 13,
she became a full timer and these were her mill clothes.
She was wearing clogs,
um,
with steel tips,
a skirt and shorts.
The shorts and other short has been put over ahead.
So you know,
it's a really powerful rather than haunting image and it was very successful and
thousands of copies of this image was sold.
Subjects can be really young,
it could be teenagers.
And this girl here was a 17 when she started a suffragette career.
She worked in a dad shop in Westminster,
had a kind of a chemist,
John.
And she got involved.
And with our father's blessing,
she'd gone involved.
Lucky girl.
Um,
but she did change her name to spare his embarrassment.
She was born Jesse Spinks.
She's such a nice name.
And she'd caught herself,
very Wentworth and that's how she known.
That's her prison record.
Noser as very what worth.
But you know,
her real name was Jessie spanx.
So you could be really young,
you could be in your 20s and 30s and forties and 50s.
And even feminists in their seventies who had fought all sorts of interesting
campaigns.
The 19th century in their seventies and early eighties were joining the
suffragette campaign,
adding that imprimatur to this movement.
And um,
marching alongside the punk code's going to parliament to talk to politicians,
to talk to politicians,
which is to insist on the vote.
It wasn't nothing to do with talking.
It was demanding.
So across the age spectrum,
women are in getting involved in the struggle and adding their own special and
unique qualities turret.
Um,
I like this image because it shows you how the,
the movement is kind of bursting out all over the country.
The map shows where they had branches in committee rooms and shops.
Uh,
it's a brilliant,
you're organized campaign.
There were,
everything was like a military maneuver.
The left nothing to chance.
They had lots of volunteers to make this happen.
They pay their organizers two pounds a week,
which a lot of the legwork was done by unpaid volunteers from all class
backgrounds,
not just middle class girls with nothing else to do.
And um,
it was,
it was well resourced.
They had a great,
a couple who were the business managers,
if you like,
they provide a lot of the seed money and they have to be a generous kind,
noble,
intelligent,
a wonderful cup of the [inaudible].
Lawrence's.
Um,
Fred was a barrister,
so we gave lots of legal advice and lots of his money was used to bail out
suffragettes from a custody until their cases were hurt at court.
So a lot of his personal fortune was going to support the campaign.
And Emily and his wife was the fundraiser.
She raised the equivalent of 3 million pounds in five years.
She,
the woman could not stop raising money.
She has dozens of ideas,
which are brilliant at filling up thief,
what they're called,
the more chest,
which is their campaign fund.
Uh,
Annie was having so much fun in the subject paint and her sister,
uh,
Jessie has come to Ron,
one of the London departments and here she is sitting in front of the map here.
She's got a senior position to so much nicer than working in a cotton mill is to
actually come to London and be part of something really vibrant and very,
very exciting.
This is the marketing and merchandising and the colors featured very
prominently.
Um,
there's sort of quite small in 19 eight with barges and resentments and sashes,
but very quickly there's a vast amount of merge available,
um,
to those women who want to buy it at the top end,
the top end,
if you were really well off,
you can't have a purple,
white and green car upholstered and decorated with suffragette logos.
So that's high end marketing.
Um,
you could get subject bicycles,
you get votes,
women's cigarettes and chocolates and moment and all kinds of food stamps.
Um,
you could get jewelry,
you could get dresses,
you could get slippers and shoes and hats decorate.
I mean whatever you wanted,
somebody out there would make it for you.
And all the big department stores in London and the major cities,
Woodstock stock,
purple,
white and green clothing and accessories for suffragette customers.
Um,
this tea set that,
that was on the market in 1909 and uh,
there are still a few around,
but they're extremely rare and very expensive.
Well,
subject campaign was,
I haven't got time to go into,
go to go into too many of the kind of year on year details,
but initially from moving away from interrupting meetings when we were bound
from political meetings,
cause you never know.
They look quite nice,
but there could be suffragettes there could be so troublesome.
They would just get up and fell a banner and shout.
We votes for women,
you know,
and a need to interrupt politicians in that making speeches.
So women were bound and and to,
and to protest that they would get onto the roofs of those buildings where they
were banned and they would have banners and they do rooftop protests like prison
protests.
They will do that.
They started it really.
And when the police,
the firemen,
we try and hose them down off the roof,
extremely dangerous.
The suffragettes got so cross,
they just rip the slates off the roof and just chop them down on the police the
low.
So you know,
these,
these protests could end up extremely violent and dangerous.
And of course it adds to their bad reputation.
It's taught politicians as well.
They would follow them around and just make their lives a total misery.
They would go to them,
they would fold into church and every button hold them and grab hold and say
when you're going to give women the vote,
they would follow them.
When they were playing golf,
they hide in the bushes and jump out and say,
what are you going to give women the vote?
Is there a really upset pain?
That was kind of slapstick.
And finally,
and I'm not so bad,
but then when the government promises to seriously consider a bill and to give
it time in parliament and allow it to become law,
when they renege on these promises,
three years running,
things taught to get really difficult.
And the suffragettes think,
okay,
we're going to move on a bit.
When I move the action a bit further down the line.
And it's extraordinary.
We say these things because these are just straightforward,
ordinary women.
You know,
they'd,
all they wanted was the vote.
They found themselves caught up in this semester,
extraordinary battle between the police,
the government,
prison authorities,
and sometimes members of the public would attack them.
You know,
it was really dangerous thing to be,
to be a suffragette.
This is one particularly dark day in 1910,
um,
suffragettes were waiting to hear about a bill that was being debated in
parliament,
just waiting to hear when the legal time table was going to be drawn up for it
to become law.
Ask with WHO's the prime minister.
Just completely tore Peter's it and says,
oh no,
no.
Well,
we're not,
haven't got time for that.
We'll think about it again next year,
and this is after a lot of peaceful lobbying and campaigning,
so they'd be set off in groups of a dozen from Caxton Hall,
whether we're meeting and waiting and they try and get into parliament and the
police are ready for them.
They know they're going to kind of make that protest and parliament square and
Winston Churchill Church was the home secretary actually recruited a lot of
policemen from these.
Dan Too are used to dealing with violent thugs and they were there but in plain
clothes they just saw that members of the crowds in terms of public and they
were all,
they were in disguise really in two ways.
They were wearing badge with budgets,
which said men's League for women's suffrage.
So they were,
they were pretending it was support as they weren't they and the uniform police
like we can see here and mounted policeman.
Actually their mission was to handle that situation in such a way that women
would never come back and protest again,
which meant that women were crushed against the railings by police horses.
They were punched,
kicked,
beaten hair,
pulled close turn dot pulled off,
um,
really badly assaulted and about 40,
where more were taken down.
Very site streets around Parliament Square and sexually assaulted by uniformed
policemen.
And these are John provocateur and the crowd,
one coach to join in.
So it's a terrible day.
It's 150 women are involved in these kinds of assault,
physical and sexual assault.
I can't sit the hall where they'd been meeting becomes like a field hospital,
um,
suffragette nurses,
nurses with softer,
that's sympathies rush there and doctors rush there to do some very basic first
aid.
But it was an awful day and it triggered riots the following weeks where
hundreds of women of being arrested,
some of them are being discharged,
but a lot of them are going to prison.
Holloway fills up and the others just bossed around the country because there's
no room in Holloway.
They've got to go to Liverpool,
Bristol,
Newcastle,
Manchester,
anywhere just to kind of to cope with them while that they're going to be
charged and senators are going to be hunted down.
It's such a difficult day.
It's such a dangerous,
horrible moment.
Mrs Ponca said,
I don't think we can do this.
We can't go to Paula Mellon less because he gives the police too much time to
molest manhandle all sorts of things are going on.
So what we need to do is we need to have protests where women are arrested
immediately.
So that's going to be like gorilla campaigning and she said we're going to have
to wage guerrilla warfare on this government because we cannot trust the police
to police these demonstrations properly.
And so guerrilla warfare,
you know the campaign goes underground in the autumn of 1910 and violence and
vandalism breaks out all over the country and the idea is smashing windows.
Yes,
they stood there and waited to be read to be arrested because that would mean
they went straight to the police station.
There's one other,
there's pushing and shelving and Catlin.
We're still happens at demonstrations.
It's,
it's,
it's a contract.
Quick protest,
the video to present,
you know,
they don't mind.
I mean they don't want to go to prison but they don't mind doing that if this is
going to further the cause.
So this is a tipping point and this day,
the 18th of November,
1910 is remembered ever after by suffragettes and for the rest of their lives as
black Friday.
People sometimes say to me,
who's your favorite suffragette?
And I say,
well,
there's about 200 of them and they're in this book,
but I'm to pick one.
I have to pay Edith rugby because she was just so gorgeous and outrageous and
unconventional.
Um,
she was adopted,
still a doctor's doctor and the doctor's wife and Preston and she,
um,
was absolutely single minded in getting the vote and focusing on working class
women.
She comes from a nice,
comfortable little horse background,
but her interests lie in votes for working women.
And she recruits local women.
She takes them down to London,
they get involved in all kinds of protests and demonstrations and you just had
to take one look at it is to know how unconventional she was.
She did not wear the normal clothes and had ward in leading course.
It's pretty dresses and that kind of stuff.
She wore her clothes that she made herself.
Um,
I suppose we think of her now perhaps is the first heppy cause they're really
big baggy dresses,
kind of homemade dresses.
She made their own jewelry and that's all a bit Bohemian and pretty but very
weird for the times.
Um,
nobody else was dressed like that and she wore sandals and we around people
thought that was weird and she chain smoked all the time.
And that was most unladylike.
So that's what Edith was like,
you know,
and she does all the,
she does the whole suffragette number.
She goes to parliament,
she protests,
she breaks windows.
She burns down houses.
Yeah,
just point out that whenever suffered,
it's burned down a house.
It was always interesting in that they're always record the place first.
It's,
their owners were still unhappy about it,
but no human life was lost.
So,
um,
for the last few months of 1913,
Edith on the run from the police,
even a husband doesn't know where she is because she's got out of prison.
Um,
cause she's been on hunger strike and she's been forced fed.
And she was released on a special license and she hides an island in Gallway and
she's there not,
not communicated with a husband or friends at all and just waiting to slip back
into the country to carry on doing more militancy.
So Edith rugby is a really interesting woman and I mean there are,
there are 200 women in this book with,
with incredible stories and they do things that I don't think many of us or any
of us would,
would be able to do now.
It required really particular mindset and phenomenal,
um,
sacrifice and courage.
I like this photograph because it's looks really modern.
Um,
it was taken by Special Branch,
um,
as a surveillance photograph,
as man hiding in a van,
in the exercise yard or in a box and exercise yard at Holloway prison.
And he used to take a patient's got no idea.
She's been photographed.
Multiple copies of these prints would be sent all over the country to police
stations to look out for women because there were very mobile,
they would arrive in places with alias,
isn't it?
And this and this and in disguise.
They moved all over the country.
They were like soldiers really in a campaign and they were turn up and they
would smash windows and they were put phosphorous bombs and pillar boxes and
they would,
um,
vandalize sports facilities.
They would get asked.
And Vernon Golf Greens,
no vote,
no golf,
that kind of stuff.
And um,
so,
so they were,
there were a tremendous problems.
The police and Special Branch had lots of detectors following them and taking
photographs of them to try and get a handle on who they were and where they were
going and what to do when they turned up at grace.
His father was a clergyman,
um,
in,
in Norfolk and to risk,
I mean,
he knew what she was up to.
He didn't try and stop her,
but to make life a bit easier for him,
they have a very distinctive surnames.
They're called mark on,
but she's got grace mark on.
So she had an alias,
quite a of suffragettes had an alias to spare their father's feelings,
even though they knew there were suffragettes.
And she caught herself free to Thomas.
And she has an interesting career in London.
She works as a gymnastics teacher and a Mizuho's,
but when she's on soft debt,
missing missions,
she's obviously not able to work and she's kind of on the run from the police.
A lot of the time it's a grace mark on is a,
is a tremendous character and she was about 20 when she got involved in this
campaign.
Well,
being a suffragette was hard.
You know,
if you try to make a speech outside perhaps in Wimbledon common or wherever,
you know,
the crowd could be really hostile,
that could be very abusive.
It could be very vulgar unless it's mostly male rough crowds who are kind of
falling your round to just beat you.
Really.
They would perhaps through,
um,
you know,
rotting fruit and vegetables,
lumps of coal,
cabbages rocks were soft,
often stoned.
Um,
Sylvia had experiences in the stand where did cats and dogs with thrown us.
So,
um,
so it was horrible and dangerous and again,
it's hard too much.
And doing that now in front of really rough crowd of course in those days was
even more unimaginable.
So there's lots of that.
There's all this stuff that's going on in prison,
which is being forced fed.
The reason why they go on hunger strike is they say,
were political prisoners.
We've been treated as common criminals.
What's what's happening?
Men who are campaigning politically and are being arrested for political crimes
that come painting methods are given special status,
right back to the 19th century.
That was,
why aren't we being given the status?
And the government would never give in on that.
They went on a hunger strike and hundreds of women were fed by force.
I'm the worst.
I'm the three ways of doing it.
I'll just go straight to the worst,
which was where liquid food is poured in a funnel down a tube,
which is pushed down your throat down here to the top of the stomach.
So it's just poured straight into your stomach.
It's,
it's melt with rural ag or it's melt with brandy or effect strap,
that kind of thing.
And you tip back in your chair,
you're held down by four water says,
and that's poured into you.
Um,
imagine no,
the gag reflex would,
would not be happy about this.
And suffragettes had their vocal cords damaged like that teeth knocked out in
the,
in the struggle,
um,
while it's being poured in there,
vomiting it straight back out again.
Um,
sometimes if you've got into the lungs and they had pleurisy pneumonia,
so it's really dangerous because with pneumonia,
this is before antibiotics.
And so,
um,
you could die from pneumonia and all the people dead.
So it's torture.
It's torture by no other name,
but hundreds of them we're doing it is their decision.
Nobody told them to do it.
And then the decision is we can a force the government to give us the vote.
So the stories of hunger,
striking force feeding a really powerful recruiting tools to women who will hear
these stories and they're going to have a response to that.
They might not want to go out and do militancy,
but they're going to give some money.
They're going to get to some time.
They're going to be involved in the campaign.
And you know,
these stories,
these moments where we're really important cause it galvanized women to support
the suffer jets.
They might not like militancy.
There might not really approve of it,
but they felt it was a means to an end.
A means to a very,
very important.
And so there's a lot of scary stuff,
dangerous stuff,
unpopular stuff you've got to kind of develop a thick skin about.
But this fund as well,
there are big on parties.
They're very big on tin cakes.
That was a big part of the kind of recruiting process.
And here the having a suffrage at sleepover there says when it's census night,
when the government sent round to count the population suffragists that we pay
taxes,
we no voice in the making of laws,
so we're not going to be counted.
The government threatened to find most and the two person didn't matter of 4,000
women don't do the sentence.
They will have parked their departed wherever they went on the night.
The gather groups together,
they hide caravans and went out on Wimbledon common and spent the night out
there.
And how the policy,
they had smoking parties,
the went rollerskating or my in,
it was a lot of fun and making it a really important political point.
Um,
you know,
uh,
no voice in our legislation,
so we're not going to be part of your official headcount.
So I like this cause it looks like it was fun.
I was very lucky to meet this lady,
um,
in the 1990s when I worked at Museum of London.
Um,
there she is as a young suffragette.
She called Victoria,
Victoria Simmons in that photo golf.
She's about 19.
She came up to London and she broke windows in Whitehall in 1912 she went to
prison for two months and she went on hunger strike,
which was force fed.
She came up with a sister Winnie.
We need managed to get away.
So when he went and sang songs every day outside Holloway prison to keep
Victoria kind of company.
Um,
and when,
when,
um,
Victoria went back to Clifton,
which is where she came from,
her local clergymen,
the man whose church she attended saw her selling a newspaper in the street and
he was so disgusted by the fact that had been to London and she did what she
did.
You just spat in her face,
which is not,
we'd expect a clergyman to do.
But people felt able to make those kind of,
um,
uh,
remarks and those kind of behaviors.
I met in 1990s when she was a hundred.
She's a hundred in that photograph and she was still a suffragette actually,
she still had that suffragette twinkle.
She still had that fire in her eyes and she'd been a political campaign all her
life.
She got married,
which was the first one.
We're not Titian.
Um,
she got involved in all kinds of animal rights campaigns and our last campaign
for the ordination of women priests,
she lived to see that happen.
And it was great.
The very first time I met her.
Well,
the only time I met him,
I spent a whole day with and it was such a thrill to actually meet someone who'd
done it,
you know,
and I could see completely how she had taken that position.
I said,
well,
let's,
um,
let's go and have some lunch shelving.
And I'm,
it's just perfectly able,
she didn't eat it walking frame or anything.
She was perfectly fine living in a flat on her own.
And she said,
well,
it'll have to be vegetarian dashes because I've been a vegetarian since 1897 so
you know,
that's,
that's actually was.
And I said,
what's it like living here in Brighton and hove?
She said,
oh,
it's all very well,
she's,
but it's full of old people.
I think she thought she was about 50 actually.
She didn't realize she was a hundred.
So it was really nice to meet her and to just kind of spend some time with
somebody who'd actually been and done the firstness.
And the last photograph and want to talk is about,
is this one here,
and this is,
um,
was taking 90,
67 and these are the magic campaigners and the militant campaigners.
They're brought together for a photo shoot.
The Observer of gathered 13 of them,
they can get together on particular day.
We're a big feature that was in the observer and I love this photograph.
I just love it because it's so colorful,
it's so vibrant.
And it's about the personalities.
I think the color of their clothes reflect the vibrancy of those characters.
And,
um,
I just wanted to point a few of my favorites.
Actually.
It's,
I'm just going to move over.
Um,
now this is like the formal photograph.
It's all kind of,
everything's okay here,
right?
But things have relaxed a bit.
By the time we get to this photo golf,
right,
of the burning down buildings,
which has interviewed years later,
her eyes lit up.
You know,
she's really excited talking about,
um,
when she brought down these buildings.
So she's in that off president.
She's on hunger strike.
She's forced that she was somebody who had food go into her lungs.
She had pleurisy pneumonia at the same time she could have died.
She was only 20 when that happened to her.
Um,
when she was charged in,
caught at both street,
the magistrate sort of centered down for six months.
She said,
oh,
well I'll be back,
you know,
next time I'm out,
I'm going to burn down two buildings a week.
You know,
that's my projects.
If she's completely kind of irrepressible um,
Angie,
because she's so small,
she could spit,
smuggled out the in laundry baskets and what they often did was they were out on
special licenses.
They're being,
they're supposed to sit in this place,
this designated to duress to get better,
to put on some weight and just wait to be rearrested.
That was the scheme.
That was a police idea.
Well they're not going to do that.
Are there,
they're going to kind of recover a bit.
You're going to put on a bit of weight,
just be looked after in like a nursing home context and then they're going to
get out.
They're not going to wait to go back to prison and carry on the whole business
again.
So they would arrange for parties of women would come to see them,
see how they're getting on flowers and chocolates,
all that [inaudible] and there'd be a body double amongst that group.
So it's an a number of times she got out by swapping clothes or somebody,
a young,
small person and she would just walk past the police who were on 24 hour guard
outside the premises where she's been looked after.
So very often she just walked straight past them,
which she goes out in a laundry basket and she had this brilliant ability and
that because she's so small actually she can be a child.
She's often dressed as a boy and that's how she gets away from the police.
So she had lots of,
she a very lengthy record,
but she hardly said anytime in prison cause she's so good at getting away.
I love her.
And this is a Mrs Gwen O'brian.
Whenever Brian was one of Mrs Pancoast body guards because there's about 40
women who were part of the body guard,
um,
who used to mop her to make joints top of being arrested by the police.
So Gwen had
many fisticuffs with the police to keep trying to stop.
This is Pancoast being arrested.
And then also I didn't want to talk about,
is this one here,
she's called owner devolve.
They need to.
Val was,
um,
again,
total career suffragette she got married in 1912 and she made a press release
before she got married and said,
I shouldn't be seeing the words I obey in the wedding service and everybody will
complete.
You're agitated about this.
The Archbishop of Canterbury said,
what are you,
you won't be married if you don't say I obey.
He says,
well,
I'm not going to say it.
So she carried on.
She got married,
she completely,
um,
kind of ignore the Archbishop of Canterbury and she just went ahead with it.
But that gives you a clue as to how,
how strong minded they were.
You know,
how dedicated they were,
how visionary they were and how insistent and persistent they were in their
views.
And uh,
she was,
uh,
she was part of a suffragette family.
Her,
she married into a family called the develop family.
So the dog,
the dog doesn't devolves numbered about six female suffragettes and two husbands
supporters.
Now they couldn't join the WSP EU,
but husbands were really important in protecting their wives,
the female relatives and friends from attacks from I needed a different
direction.
And so this important family,
the dog,
the Duvall's,
we're part of this whole family of suffrage.
I think all the women who got involved in suffrage felt they were part of a
family and you really need to feel that to actually be able to keep doing it
because it was hard.
Um,
did it involved off of sacrifice and quite a lot of suffering.
Okay.
That's what I want to say about the images.
I'm very happy to take questions if you,
I'll try not to them.
Okay.
My question was,
have you been always been talking about this and researching this for a very
long time and in time in doing so and more recently,
have you found the conversation has changed if your audiences change to become
more receptive,
more understanding?
Yes.
I mean for,
I've been involved with the subject for a long,
long time.
And for years there was no love in the room for the suffragettes.
People couldn't stand them.
Even academics,
even historians were quite dismissive of them.
They believed the lie that it was just middle class women looking after their
own interests.
But now there's quite a lot of love and lots of rooms where I talk about the
suffragettes cause people can hear really the full story and understand about
their characters and their strengths and their courage and their commitment.
And I think that the people that women that lots of people can be proud of and,
but the,
the,
the mood and the attitude has shifted as the full store of the involvement in
their struggle actually emerges.
Hi.
Um,
so I've got questions.
So I kind of feel
right now with the meaty trend.
Um,
I feel that we are perhaps living through another pivotal moment as we did a
hundred years ago with the suffrage jazz.
I don't know if you would agree with that.
And my question to you is,
do you feel,
I mean,
I guess I've got two questions.
One I wouldn't tell whether these ladies would feel proud of where we are right
now as a society or whether they think actually hasn't moved on enough because I
personally feel we're still quite far from jet true gender equality.
Um,
and my second question to you is,
with this pivotal moment that we're living through now with the me too trend,
do you feel this will result in significant move towards kind of genuine gender
quality and the kind of world I guess these ladies hoped they would achieve?
Well,
uh,
I mean,
excuse me,
that's two good questions.
I think that the suffragettes um,
thought a lot of this would have been sorted out by now.
Um,
you know,
I think one of that,
one of the,
uh,
[inaudible] one of their wishes was equal pay.
They're talking about equal pay,
you know,
at the turn of the century and before.
So they'd be very disappointed about the inequity of unequal pay.
And they would say,
I'm sure.
How did you let this go on for so long?
Don't forget,
in 1970,
the equal pay act was passed.
It's supposed to be right across the board,
fully implemented by 1975 and it still hasn't happened.
So they,
they think that was weird,
which I think is code for shockingly bad.
Um,
I think the me too moment is going to actually,
I think,
I think both of these issues are going to result a result in something in some
part because I think so many people are affected by it.
It can't just be,
um,
uh,
caught me just papered over.
It can't be ignored.
It can't be brushed under the carpet.
So many people have,
have the issue of unequal pay as sexual harassment.
I can't see that.
It,
nothing can happen.
But I think what we do,
and the suffragettes would say,
well,
how,
how did this go on for so long?
Um,
because suffragettes were,
were campaigning for the vote to stop sexual harassment.
And they said,
well,
we haven't got that yet.
They,
I think they would like us to have Mrs Pancha slogan at the top of our wines.
Deeds not words.
Stop talking about it.
Stop having committee meetings about it.
Just talk about it.
But make a strategy as to how it's going to happen.
What,
what are we going to do about it?
How we're going to bring this,
I'm going to deliver these changes because talking about it just isn't enough.
And that's what he says.
Pancoast,
we'd love us to revive her slogan.
Deeds,
not words.
And I think we perhaps ought to think about that.
Yeah.
Thanks.
[inaudible].
Um,
I suppose along that the deeds,
not words so much,
and you talked about essentially ask with going back on his promises,
he says,
yes,
we'll do it.
And then not.
And then the suffragettes feeling that they had to escalate the types of actions
to what it,
to what extent do you think they'd actually,
if you want real change,
that extreme actions actually take you to a place that dialogue just,
just can't do.
Is it,
is it something that is real change?
Can it be achieved with,
with dialogue or do you have in a democracy actually need to,
to demonstrate your frustration,
anger and more sort of vocal extreme.
I mean,
I don't know if I've been taken over by suffragette spirits as possible at harm,
but I,
I don't,
I don't think dialogues in off,
I think extreme action,
whatever that is,
whether it's a general strike,
women going on strike and not doing any work at all for I do,
but it's got to,
it's got to be strong because talking just talk,
it's so easy.
It's so cheap.
It's how we,
how do you make,
how do you translate that into something?
And although government's never want to agree or conceived,
you know,
they always give in to violence and extremism.
Eventually you just have to manage that really carefully.
But they will always have to make some concessions because you can't have,
you know,
the country at war that you,
you use is this can't go on.
So I think the suffragettes were right to proceed this campaign.
They suffered enormously because of it.
But in the end,
the net result of it was during the war when they realized that,
um,
a lot of soldiers had accident.
He lost the right to vote because they were away from home and hadn't been
registered.
It's just a technical thing.
Once they realize that had happened,
they had to quickly ran franchisement it cause it's sort of a PR nightmare.
Um,
they then just say,
well all these men are fighting that.
We've got a large number of men who haven't got the,
that we've got to enfranchise them because they are putting their lives at
laying their lives down for our country and our empire.
So the soldiers are,
you know,
reinvent sheisty 21 year olds men,
uh,
reinforced draw circles and projects.
Of course a bolt,
the board.
There's also like what,
how are we going to reward women for Woolworth's because we'll work done by
women was critical.
The home front,
that war was fought and won by women.
So they have to make some kind of remark about that.
And that meant that women over 30 with certain property qualifications got the
vote.
And I really feel that if the suffragette co hadn't pushed the struggle to the
top of the agenda,
that wouldn't have happened.
The thought of the Cipher Jack campaign starting up again,
if they didn't,
even when the vote was just couldn't,
just couldn't face it.
There's so much to be done once the war was over that dealing with that as well.
And also the software just would be so,
uh,
re invigorated by the moral high ground of saying,
hang on,
what more do women have to do to,
to get the vote?
No,
we've,
we've fought the war.
The men has been at the front and we fought the war at home.
So I think the suffragettes created a mood whereby the women have to get the
vote.
I mean it was unfortunate that they weren't all in franchise on equal age thing,
but if they had been women that would have been in the majority and the
publicity was just,
couldn't we contemplate you tell me.
We think now more,
why not?
But at that time,
going from like no votes,
women telling a woman in the majority of their lecture,
that was just scary and it was just very unappetizing.
So I think,
I think the extremism of the suffragettes actually counted for something when it
came to,
um,
the,
you know,
the representation of the people aren't.
And that's how women got the vote.
Sorry it was a long winded answer but it's quite complex.
Question.
Hi there.
Thank you so much for joining.
Where did your personal interest in this topic come from?
I worked at Museum of London and they have this really important world class
collection called the suffragette fellowship collection.
And it's such a touching story because when the,
when the vote was won 1920s,
I always imagine what they did with themselves after that really exciting
campaign and the war period.
Cause they're all involved in all kinds of woodwork.
And I,
and I thought,
and now I know what they did.
They collect stuff to remember the campaign.
They had this fellowship to remember the Pancoast and to remember militancy and
they gathered all the banners and posters and stuff and they made this huge
archive and they had a little museum and Cornwell road and you could just go
along and kind of look at banners and,
and it was like a very amateurish thing,
but it was a collection that was growing and growing and growing.
People would donate and a hunger strike,
metals that jewelry,
the everything.
And we had this at the Museum of London.
I used to just go and spend hours kind of messing around and they're looking at
stuff and picking up photographs and just learning about them,
finding names to put these photo goals.
And so I kind of immersed myself in ards and like started getting like on a
compulsion to write about them and just to work out what the stories were.
And I curated an exhibition in 1992 called purple,
white and green,
which talked about marketing is the foreground of the campaign.
If my exhibition in the background,
the backdrop was really busy and I've just kept with it and I had a break from
writing about them.
I did other biographies of women and I kind of came back to them.
I'm thinking,
yeah,
right,
okay,
let's get biographical where this lot and find out what's,
you know,
how this all came about.
So my book is a collective biography of 200 suffragettes and,
um,
and I say I'm,
I'm,
I think I'm possessed by them because everyday I think about them,
you know,
I kind of think,
oh,
I want to eat at the Rick.
We would have done about what would eat if they've done,
you know.
So,
uh,
no,
they're really inspiring.
They're amazing.
I love them.
Yeah.
In the last couple of elections we've seen the women's equality party come to
more prominence,
at least before d.
What's your take on,
on that movement?
And is that just a modern embodiment of the suffragette spirits,
or is it maybe a pale imitation and what would be,
what would the Pacific let's do in the current political climate?
Well,
I think the suffragettes would say we should have had the women's equality party
a long time ago.
I think they support them.
I think they would endorse a lot of their policies.
I think they'd like what they're doing.
They'd approve of it certainly.
And I think they'd want us all to vote for them.
Uh,
and I think lots of people say to me,
what do you,
what,
what should I do?
I did an event at wow,
at the royal festival on Saturday,
11 of the world.
And I talked about and a young woman still at what can I do?
What can I do about this?
I said,
well,
join the women's equality party.
And sadly she said,
I've never heard of them.
So my mission would be my advice to women's equality.
Get out there,
get no more,
get some candidates,
get some money and try and think about adopting some of these suffragette
tactics because I think that's what lots of women want and need.
Um,
so we talked about it before you started.
We talked about technology and the impact that can have.
And one of the themes that you brought up was how organized the suffragettes.
Where do you think that technology is supposed to be?
Hindering the ability to get out he consistent organized message to achieve an
individual goal.
So for example,
women's equality party,
there are too many voices asking for too many different things.
Yes.
I think the suffered on the virtues of the suffragettes was that,
you know,
there were very clear,
the word democratic then we're interested in committees.
They just walked,
they made policy and they wanted their supporters to follow the policy.
And it's quite straight forward in where,
because I often think one way of making sure things don't happen to have a
committee because he just takes her long,
it becomes a talking shot.
I'm sorry.
But it just is so frustrating.
It just ends up to being a little about the committee,
not about the project and the goal.
So I think they need to have a single issue or a big identifiable message and to
push that because that will bring so many people together.
We're reasons why the suffragette campaign was so diverse and so,
so huge.
Really.
Um,
is the fact they're going for the vote,
the vote,
the vote.
And that brings a lot of people too.
I like campaign and very importantly,
great diverse talent and it's talent that has so many impacts,
which isn't just so many aspects of the organization.
So I think a single issue campaign is something that really has a chance of
success because you've got numbers,
you've got diversity,
and that's where I think results can be gained more quickly.
I thought her,
I think the is would love social media,
the way they would've loved tweeting and um,
Instagram,
they would have loved that.
They would have really embraced that.
They took the technology that was available at the time to the Max.
So they really worked on that.
So they think,
hey,
you've got Twitter,
you've got all this stuff.
What,
what's happened
to be nice?
You mentioned 200,
200 women,
200 suffragettes yeah,
I was wondering,
are there any prominent male,
um,
can we say suffragettes well,
yeah,
they,
they couldn't,
well,
I call them.
And you came across.
Yeah.
Well,
there's some good guys.
There are lots of good guys.
Um,
Edith rigbys husband was a doctor,
Charlie,
and he was just like the ideal husband.
He just let it go that,
you know,
he never stopped.
He was worried about hunger,
striking bigger doctor.
But he didn't ever try and stop her.
And a lot of the time when she was just in Ireland had no idea where she was.
And a family friend wrote and said,
Oh,
I'm so sorry about this is all very trying for you,
isn't it?
He said,
I don't want your sympathy.
I don't need it because I back Edith in everything she does.
She has the courage of a lion and I don't have the moral courage that she has,
so I will back her whatever she does now,
that's quite an admission for a man at that time to make.
So there are lots of good men like,
um,
Charlie rugby,
but they suffered,
you know,
their reputations amongst other men.
Men thought they were like,
we meet,
you know,
men in dresses,
they said there were unsexed they work sex treaters.
So,
um,
some of their careers stuff for the reputation suffered,
their friendships were broken.
But there are some,
there are some good men in Narberth to thank you so much and I think they're
not.
I was really excited to read the book.
Thank you very much for coming.